avec un peu d'Ombre,
nous ferons un autre cercle pour
toi, ça a l'air mieux avec la glace ouais
non faible, tout
a fondu, ça commence chez Mary, le
gamin joue toujours à
l'école et le quad passe, vois
ça, ouais, nous l'avons, nous l'avons  exactement pareil exactement exactement
le même
plan oh le vélo C s'est arrêté et
continuons et les enfants dans le terrain de jeu
comme l'autre jour de football sauf que c'est
la deuxième moitié du
match le
changement les équipes jouent dans l'autre
sens où
nous marchions là-bas  il y a une semaine ouais, nous
sommes restés
ici, rappelez-vous maintenant vous, nous avons
marché sur l'eau, là-bas, une
centrale électrique de communication moderne, là-
bas, au fond des chiens de chasse, ils ne sont
plus là, d'accord, qu'avons-nous d'autre, nous avons le
bureau de poste avec ce bâtiment bleu
je suis un peu par ici,
ok, faisons nos valises
oh, ils ont aussi un drapeau canadien ouais,
les enfants de l'école ouais,
là, ils n'ont pas tellement de vêtements
maintenant, tu peux voir qui ce
sont les gars par rapport aux
filles, ce serait plutôt sympa  tu sais, pour
regarder l'autre plan, voir
exactement ce que nous avons fait et pour obtenir exactement le
même plan
ouais, quelqu'un les prend en photo
oh ouais assis sur le
tambour oh il y a un
caméraman là-bas, un gars avec un handicam
là-bas, ouais, comprends ça  bateau dans le bateau
oh bateau dans le forr désolé bateau dans le
forr
un peu vite
hé ok ok
emmène-moi à ta
pompe à carburant ouais
nous sommes maintenant sur
la dernière
vitesse à l'étranger il
y a quelques gars qui partent juste pour le
déjeuner il ne reste plus personne
il fait un  beaucoup de poussière je suis
sûr que
le gars est là, il nous attend
en fait
ok arrête
d'enregistrer ok prêt ouais nous avons ce
gros truc derrière
nous
1 2
412 tests à
ultimator
2999 pas de rapport traic
2999 merci ok
ouais prêt à grogner tu vas
bien  Sur la photo, pourriez-vous répéter
votre
identification oui, c'est un renard Victor
Hotel
Xray Victor Hotel
XR et vous vérifier à
18 h 41. Oui, c'est déjà activé avec
la radio.